- He's an American entrepreneur,
author and speaker.
He's widely respected as one
of the world's most well known
and respected internet marketers.
He teaches through a
mix of video training,
webinars written, guides,
one-on-one training
and seminars.
He's Eben Pagan
and here his top 10 rules for success.
- He says rich is a state of mind.
And that if you're rich on the inside
you can then go create money
but if you're not rich on the inside,
if you don't have a rich state of mind
not only will you not be able to attract
and create money
but if you do get some
you'll find a way to get rid of it.
Right a way that I have of seeing it
is that there's a big difference
between money and wealth.
And wealth comes
from having knowledge,
systems, assets, understanding
of how to create value for others
and having systems
and assets that create value
whereas money is just these
you know imaginary numbers
and these worthless pieces of paper
that we you know try to pretend
to have value.
So success is about fulfillment.
And I think fulfillment
is about creating success for yourself
but then creating success for others
in helping them succeed.
Have you ever seen Stephen Covey
talking about how
you have to put the big rocks in your day
or else they they won't go in.
And so what he'll do is
he takes a big fish tank
and on the table he has some big rocks
and then he has some smaller rocks
and then he has some pebbles
and then he has some sand.
Okay and so what he does
is first he starts by putting
all the sand into the tank
and then he puts in the little pebbles
and then he puts in the bigger rocks
and by the time he's done
the tank is almost full
and he can't fit in the
big rocks that he has.
They just kind of sit on top
and there's nowhere to put most of them.
But then what he does
is he takes the big rocks
and he puts them into the tank first
and then he takes the smaller rocks
and he he puts them in
and he fits them around the bigger rocks.
Then he takes the little pebbles
and he puts them in
and they fit in around
the the smaller rocks
and the bigger ones.
And then he pours a ton of sand in there
which fills all the cracks up.
And the lesson is
that you have to put
in the big rocks first
or else they'll never go in.
Okay and the interesting
thing about the big rocks
is that they have to be chosen in advance.
In other words you must identify
what your most valuable activities are
and then install them in
your day ahead of time
because if you don't, okay,
other people will have
things for you to do.
Other people will take your attention.
And I can almost guarantee you
that these other things
that other people have
for you are less important
but in the moment
they seem a lot more urgent.
Okay so you got to put
the big rocks in first
and very importantly
you have to know what they are.
Don't keep your best ideas secret.
Most of the business owners that I know
whenever they figure out something
that's really fantastic,
a thing that would
really help prospects out
they start scheming
about how to sell it for a lot of money
and about how to get people
to give them money
before they reveal this secret to them
or this product or this service
or this this information.
Well guess what?
If you don't show people what you've got
and you don't prove to them
that you have a lot of value
they're not going to
pay any attention to you
at all.
A different mindset that I've developed
and learned over the last several years
is that if you will take your best ideas,
the ones that are the most valuable,
the ones that you might consider
to be the silver bullets,
the magic bullets,
the ones that work every time,
that give instant results,
that eliminate hassle
and friction from a person's life,
and you give those away,
the prospect will say to themselves
oh geez if this is what they're giving way
how much better must be the product
that they're selling?
So the advice that I have for you is
ask yourself right now
what is the one thing
that you've figured out
over your lifetime
and over your career
that can help your prospects out the most?
The thing that can give
them the most value,
eliminate the most friction
and hassle from their life,
alright the thing that works,
every single time.
What's the magic bullet
that you figured out?
The one that before you heard this
you would never share with anyone.
Okay good.
What I'd like you to do now
is make a commitment to
yourself to give it away
and give it away to as many people
as you possibly can.
By the way this is the kind of thing
that will create viral marketing for you.
This is the kind of thing that
you give it away
people will start talking about it.
They'll start coming to you
and saying wow that's an incredible idea,
do you have any more?
And I advise you to give away even more
of your good ideas.
Now language is part of communication
but there's a much bigger piece
of communication than language
which is the nonverbal communication
that happens between people.
Most persuasion, most bonding,
most connection happens on channels
other than the words.
Right so you've heard
the the old estimates
that you know over 90%
of your communication
is your voice tone and your body language.
Communication is so important.
And what's amazing is most people
are just unconscious.
They're not paying any attention to it.
They're not learning how to communicate
with and connect with other people better.
So learn about body language.
Learn about nonverbal communication.
Learn about how to connect with people
and build rapport.
So I think of entrepreneurship
as being like an ultimate training ground,
an ultimate practice place
to learn the basic skills
that we need to learn
in order to then come back
and be great at contribution.
Steven Covey has the model
of first we start out dependent
and then we become independent
and then we become interdependent.
And in developmental models
if you study developmental psychology
which I recommend you do
in any of the developmental models
each level acts as a foundation
for the next level.
So if we don't become
powerfully independent
we can't become powerfully interdependent.
And I think of entrepreneurship
as being the best school now
for becoming powerfully independent.
Robert Kiyosaki who
wrote Rich Dad Poor Dad
and Cash Flow Quadrant
and some other books
that are excellent initial training,
he's got this model where he says
we start out as employee
and then we go to self-employed
and then we become business owners
and then we become investors
and then I would add
then we become philanthropists ideally,
we'd become people
to come back and contribute.
And these build upon each other.
Okay so when you're an employee
you learn some tasks some skills.
You do them.
You get a paycheck.
When you become self-employed
now you're responsible.
You have to go get the business as well.
Then when you're a business owner
you create that organism or that entity
that then runs and throws off the profit.
And then when you become an investor
you invest in those types of entities.
And then ideally
when you become a philanthropist
or someone that's contributing
you start investing in the most important
you know biggest widest
scale kind of projects.
And I say that model, those five steps,
because entrepreneur, business owner
is in the middle.
And what I want to emphasize
is that entrepreneurship
and owning and building a business,
it's one step in a much bigger puzzle.
It's not the end.
And unfortunately
I see a lot of entrepreneurs get stuck
at that step.
They get to that level
and they start becoming very successful
and then they just want more
and bigger
and you know more money
and more power
rather than realizing
oh that's just one step
that I need to become competent in
so that I can go on to the next level
and go on to the next level.
So what's the difference
between these levels?
Well essentially the difference is
each one becomes more complex
and more multi-dimensional
and has a longer time horizon.
Alright so when you're an employee
you're just doing your work
to get your paycheck in two weeks.
When you're self-employed
all of a sudden the time horizon moves out
and you learn about invoicing
and you learn that
companies don't pay invoices
as fast as you used to get your paycheck.
And then when you become a business owner,
an entrepreneur you know kind of proper,
you start thinking in timeframes
of months and in years in terms of return.
You become an investor.
You start thinking in
terms of multiple years
or even decades.
And then philanthropist,
you know you look way
out onto the horizon.
And I say this because
because each level builds
on the previous levels
this entrepreneur level
where you you start
learning to manage a team,
to manage resources,
to think in multi-year time horizons,
it's a really important step
for us to all go through.
And when I hear people tell me
that they want to make
an impact on the world
and they go straight
from you know high school to that
or sometimes straight from college to that
and they don't get a
little experience working
in the entrepreneurial world
my heart sinks a little bit
because I think they're not going to be
as powerful at making a difference
or an impact in the world
as they would have been had they gone
and made themselves strong
and powerful and successful first.
Start habitualizing or ritualizing
or systemizing or
routineizing those things
that are the most important things
and start doing them every
day at the same time.
And what you'll find
is that especially in the work arena,
in business, if you will make rituals
and routines out of the
very high value things
in your life every day,
you'll do them at the
same time automatically
because if you think about it
you already do the same things
every day at the same time automatically.
When we procrastinate
what we're usually doing
is resisting doing something different
than we normally do.
Right we have our routines that we're in.
We're all creatures of habit.
We'd like to do the same things
at around the same times every day.
And when we're procrastinating
what we're doing is going
oh I don't really want to do
that thing right now.
Sometimes we don't know why.
We're coming up with a bunch of excuses.
It's usually just
because it's not a habit.
It's not a routine.
It's not something that
we do automatically
every day.
As an example
I struggled for years
with trying to get my sleep
and my exercise and my diet
all in shape.
Well that all changed
when I built a simple routine
where I go to sleep at the same time.
I wake up around the same time
and then I do my exercise first thing
and then I eat a healthy meal first thing.
And then I just made
a routine out of that.
So I go to sleep.
I get enough sleep.
I wake up.
First thing that I do
is I make sure that I get my exercise
and then I have a healthy meal.
And now I'm pulled
into these routines every day
and I don't have to worry
about procrastinating
because it's a ritual.
It's something that I
do the same everyday.
Now it takes 30 days or so
to actually create a new habit.
So you got to force yourself to do it
at the same time every day.
At 2 to 3 weeks
you'll notice it gets easier and easier.
And then in about a month
you're just doing the
exact same thing every day.
You're pulled into it.
You find yourself doing it automatically.
And this is the one where everyone goes
I don't want to be a salesperson right.
You know one of the things
that we do in our business
is we take experts
and we teach them how to package
their information up into products
like ebooks and other information products
and sell them.
Well when I start talking to these experts
almost universally they say things like
I've got all the content,
I just need to find someone
who can market and sell it for me.
And when I say to them
well you know what would probably be good
for you is to actually
learn some marketing
and sales they go
oh I don't want to learn.
I'm not a salesman.
They kind of like look
down at sales people
like it's some like lower form
of human business scum
or something like that.
And you know you imagine okay
I have to put on a funky like a weird suit
and like a windbreaker
like a car salesman in
order to sell my product.
I would never want to do that.
Well when you really learn sales
as I know you know
because you're a fantastic salesperson
that the best selling methods
are consultative selling
where you don't sit down
and try to talk someone into buying.
You sit down and you say
let me ask you some questions.
Let me learn about you
and find out what all your problems are
and let me see if what
I have is even a fit.
And then once you've found out
where they're at, what their problems are,
what all the challenges
they're facing are,
what they'd like to accomplish,
then you sell solutions.
You sell them fixing their problems.
You sell them getting what they want
not your thing.
And the best of the best
of the best salespeople
are the ones that walk in, sit down
and ask a bunch of questions
and then say my product can't help you,
let me refer you to someone who can,
because those are the people
that win the trust
and that when they say
this is the thing that
will solve your problem
the prospect says that's the thing I need
because they're trustworthy.
So learning consultative selling
and really learning how to
sell like a professional
is very important.
Know thyself.
Know thyself:
this is probably the most famous phrase
handed down from the Greek philosophers.
Know thyself;
Why is it so important?
Why is it so profound?
And another question.
Why do we do what we do?
Why do we think the way we think?
Why do we feel the way we feel?
Why do we behave in certain patterns
and get into certain relationship patterns
in our lives?
Well these are the magic questions.
Psychology answers these questions
on the general level
but we all have experiences
that are private very individual
and very powerful.
We have something
that's shaping our thoughts,
shaping our emotions,
shaping our behavior from the inside.
Why is it so important to know yourself?
What does it mean?
Well I don't think it means
to know what your favorite TV show is
or what your favorite restaurant is.
I do think to know yourself means
to understand your personality,
to understand how you're wired,
what you're likely to do
in different situations,
under different types of pressure
and with different types of people.
The reason that it's so
important to know thyself
is because there are many
different types of people in the world
and to create success
you must work effectively with yourself
and with others.
You must know yourself.
You must know how you work
so you can control yourself,
communicate well
and understand what
others are communicating
and ultimately increase your effectiveness
communicating and persuading others
and creating the results
that you want in your life.
It's also critical to know yourself
so you can understand your weaknesses,
your soft spots, your Achilles heels
and those things in your life
that can hurt you.
All of these things are
intimately connected
to your personality.
Understanding your personality
is understanding yourself.
If you'd like to know thyself
then know thy personality.
In the past the paradigm that we use
as business owners and marketers
is that we have some entry-level stuff
that we use to get prospects' attention.
And those things might
be like advertisements
or we might offer you know
some free information
or a free report
or sometimes even free recorded messages
or free consultations.
And then we move
and we have the kind of
mid-level priced products
that we sell and upsell to.
And then we have our highest end products
that we sell to our best customers.
Well what's happening now
and what's happening a lot
and accelerating over the last few years
with the rise of the Internet
is more and more stuff
is available for free.
There are more companies
that are funded by venture capital
that have 50 million
dollars in cash in the bank
that they don't know what to do with.
So they're just giving
stuff away to customers.
Things are becoming cheaper
and cheaper to produce.
And all that stuff
that you used to think of
as being your real valuable stuff,
now you've got your competitors
giving it away to your customers.
So if you can't beat them
you need to join them.
And in fact what I think you need to do
is get in front of them.
And what we do
is we take that line,
that was the stuff
that we used to give away for free
and we move it deeper
into the customer relationship.
And the things
that we used to charge money for,
our entry-level products,
now we give away.
And what that does
is it builds relationships
with more customers.
It allows us to kind of widen our funnel
so to speak
and attract a lot more prospects.
So let me give you an example
from one of our current businesses.
As I mentioned before we have a company
called Double Your Dating.
And in that company
we teach dating advice to men.
Now we actually have another company
that we teach dating advice to women
and we have others
that we teach other kind of self-help
and personal development topics.
But the one that started it all
was the company called Double your Dating.
And when I originally sat down
to work on the marketing for that company
I started playing around
with email newsletters.
And at first the newsletters
that I sent out were very short
and there were excerpts
of some of our products
and other stuff that wasn't
really all that valuable
but it was free
and I thought that people
would you know kind of
find some value in it.
We started sending them out.
Well as we developed I
started writing longer
and longer newsletters and I realized
that the more valuable the newsletter
the more it caused people
to want to invest in our products.
And at one point I said to myself
you know what,
I want to create the
most valuable newsletter
that has ever been created
on any topic ever in history
and then I want to give it away.
I set the bar very high.
And when I was thinking this
I was thinking about financial newsletters
that sometimes cost
thousands of dollars a year.
I mean I was really
putting the bar up there.
And if you've ever read
some of our newsletters
you'll see that they average
probably fifteen or twenty pages long
and we send them out
every couple of days.
Some of them are as long as 30 or 40 pages
of value jam-packed with entertaining,
useful, step-by-step, mindsets,
everything that you could possibly need.
And we get letters
from all around the world
constantly talking of appreciation,
thanking us for the value that we jam-pack
into these newsletters.
If you subscribe to that newsletter
and you're interested
in getting dating advice
you will have your pitcher
filled up to the brim.
Now, I recommend that you ask yourself
how can you move the free
line in your business?
You might not want to
go overboard like we did
but what's an entry level product
that doesn't cost you much to produce
that you can just give
away to your customers?
If you don't use information products
in your business, things
like email newsletters,
and downloadable ebooks,
and CD and DVD courses,
and streaming video
like you're watching right now,
then you really need to do that
and you need to learn about it
as soon as you possibly can.
The idea of bringing light to failures.
Right and you mentioned
that in our business
we try to encourage people
as soon as you see something
that goes wrong
or you screw something up
raise your hand
and say hey I screwed-up
or I see something that's wrong over here
and make it a win.
And I just want to just
slip this in there.
The reason why that's so important
is that we humans don't like
to look bad in front of others.
We don't like to look like idiots.
We don't like to screw things up.
So what we do in a business
or a corporate environment
is we screw something up
and then we take it and we hide it
and we isolate.
We try to not let anyone see it.
We try to go to work fixing it.
Unfortunately if you've
screwed something up
it probably means
that you didn't know
how to do it right the first time
and it probably also means further
that if you take it and
isolate and try to fix it
you're probably going
to even make it worse.
And if you let people have that mentality
of you're going to get in trouble
if you screw something up
they're going to isolate.
They're going to go try to fix it.
They're going to make it worse
and then when they show up
and it gets discovered
they might try to use a scapegoat
and say it wasn't my fault
or someone else did it.
And you know it's just
a really bad situation.
So if you can make an environment
or culture where finding screw-ups,
raising your hand when
something goes wrong,
saying I made a mistake is a win
and the person to spot
the screw-up the fastest
is the biggest winner,
then I think you can
move forward very quickly
and you can as W. Edwards Deming said
you can drive out fear
which is one of the most important things
you can do in an organization.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video
because Corpus Forte asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next.
Leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Eben Pagan's top 10 rules
hit you the hardest.
Leave it in the comments
and I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe
and I'll see you soon.